light and Magnus he's going to deliver
Checkmate it's Unstoppable now Checkmate
coming on this square or Checkmate
coming via the Knight on the Square two
threats and the white king is doomed
Max is going to win yeah all right guys
he shakes his head he can see that he's
losing game number two as well is this
due to some inaccuracies by him or his
Magnus again playing
incredible chess I mean we can't fault
Eric I see yes he blundered but it's
from a human point of view magnus's move
was just genius right yeah and to have
calculated that and there was such a
narrow path as well he forced Magnus to
find like three or four only moves to
win anything else Eric glycer would have
been winning so he kind of gambled Eric
I see and didn't pay off but
and was it that night move by Magnus
there and here we go wow Magnus Carlsen
is up by two points now in the final
everybody with the white pieces he loses
and 30 moves minus Carlson is on fire
and it's gonna be super dramatic